[Musique]
non
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro dovi de
lecture nathalie wolf
comment ça va ça va très bien c'est le
bonheur non c'est le bonheur ça vous
voulez il est faut du culot avec votre
invité jm r bonjour alors j'apprécie
toujours mrc eu de 0,1 c voilà mais nous
avons un appel samedi que j aime et
c'est bien ça oui mrc jean marcel jean
bart selva mais c'est votre nom
d'écrivain
donc on va parler de ce livre formidable
qui nous a fait énormément rire
nathalie et moi j'ai dit le mot sur vous
d'abord vous êtes prof de français
vous collaborez aussi au magazine fluide
glacial et vous aussi avec avec l'équipe
des auteurs de groland
vous avez publié votre premier roman en
2006 était déjà chez buchet chastel
éditeurs auxquels vous êtes fidèles ça
plaît prenez soin du chien c'était une
enquête assez déjanté qui mettait aux
prises des locataires de deux immeubles
jumeaux qui se font face
puis il ya eu d'autres romans comme made
in china qui raconte les aventures d'un
chinois noir à la recherche de ses
origines la fin du monde du retard en
roman construit sous la forme d'un une
course poursuite
et puis qui a tué l'homme omar qui nous
a valu en 2019 le prix paris polar faut
dire que voilà vous vous amusez à
changer de genre mais il ya toujours ce
qu'on retrouve toujours dans vos dons
vous vous livre ses cures un humour
corrosif un peu décalé et une vision de
la société et c'est ce qui se passe dans
ce nouveau roman nathalie le bonheur est
au fond du couloir à gauche
oui le bonheur est au fond du couloir à
gauche alors le pix michel achète un
héros dépressif il faut dire qu'il est
né le 1er jour du génocide rwandais
il a prononcé son premier mot le jour de
la mort de françois mitterrand il le
premier vous c'était trop sachs
le 11 septembre 2001 il ay là son
premier chagrin d'amour est donc bon
bref çà çà çà continue puisqu'il vient
d'être quitté par sa compagne bérénice
est alors michel décide de se révolter
contre son destin et il va se donner
pour cela 12 heures 12 heures pour faire
revenir sa sa dulcinée et retrouver le
bonheur donc un sacré programme
alors est ce que justement jmr parce que
votre héros et paumé et malheureux et
voit qu'il est très drôle
vous êtes de ceux qui pensaient que le
malheur est une source d'inspiration
infinie pour l'humour l'amour se nourrit
essentiellement du malheur des autres
et puis surtout de son prof à la barre
c'est à dire que l'humour est à la fois
une façon de se sauver du malheur passer
du baume sur le malheur lui donc ses
malheurs et moore sans indissociables et
c'est vrai que ce michel hache qui va
essayer donc comme dit nathalie de
retrouver et ça bérénice parti et le
bonheur alors ils essayent plein de
trucs un yaya le nutella il ya le tri
des déchets il ya y aller les forums
deschamps sur l'amour il ya même une
pour ce même mot suicider mais il trouve
ce qu'a laissé la seule chose qui allait
s'avérer 10 ans et appartements c'est ce
sont les livres de développement
personnel alors à autre le les livres de
développement personnel depuis quelques
quelques médicaments et dit qu'il va
trouver de le buzzer ya parmi ses livres
il y en a un qui s'appelle le bonheur à
monter soi même qui est l'oeuvre d'un
fedotov suédois et qui en plus fait ikea
est ce assez
c'est vrai que c'est d'abord très drôle
mais c'est vrai que c'est on est en
plein dans notre société comme on a
l'impression que le bonheur c'est un
titre qu'on pourrait monter un c'est ça
c'est actuellement un libre et lyng et
les livres de développement personnel ou
les archives ou donc un succès
absolument phénoménale
c'est ce qui m'a intéressé pour écrire
cette histoire comment se fait-il que
dans nos sociétés où nous avons atteint
vos deux corps matériel humain
extraordinaire comment se fait-il que
les gens se disent aussi malheureux et
recours comme ça des recettes du bonheur
dont géraldine a comme dans l'humour on
l'est tout autant
l'amplification bien passé un personnage
qui allait dépasser une a eu ses
recettes pour essayer de voir ce que ça
pourrait donner en 16es voilà c'est
cette idée que l'on peut fabriquer le
bonheur qui me qui m'intéresse vous avez
jamais il à l'envi comme ça de la dcri
parce qu'on voit bien que ce que vous
pourriez faire une parodie de livres des
développements par seconde non on peut
cuire effectivement des parodies de
donner au point fr et on pouvait le
faire oui je ne suis pas sûr que sur la
durée ça soit très agréable à lire on
sait rien compris au sérieux après tout
alors qu'à l'intérieur du roman vous
pouvez justement passé en revue et
donner des extraits et je pense que
c'est les extraits qui vont être
intéressant de digérant les ranger son
appartement comme le propose 7
best-seller japonaise qui est qui qui
qui propose wydad at-elle de bonheur par
le rangement d'autres temps de régime
alimentaire notre en faisant du sport là
et en chine je travaille plus sur des
extraits comme ça qu'ils forment une
sorte de petites saynètes de petits
sketches qu'il y ait eu met en scène le
héros à la recherche du bonheur oui et
justement ces livres d'ailleurs sont
vraiment à l'image de notre société au
fond recherche du prêt à consommer du
prix à penser même l'impression de vivre
dans une société où on doit être coaché
pour tout comme si nous ne savions plus
tellement au fond affronter nos doutes
nos contradictions nous nos échecs
oui c'est d'ailleurs le gros problème et
là grosse culpabilité du personnage de
michel h c'est à dire qu'il a bien
conscience d'être dans une situation où
ils devraient être heureux puisqu'il est
dans un pays
wade en sécurité où il mange à sa faim
ou wii la wii les chauffer mort il dit
sans aucune difficulté
ils sont payés même là le rêve de
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
le monde qui vit dans des conditions
épouvantables et qu'ils voient comme un
eldorado notre continent est pourtant
lui se sent malheureux donner cette
culpabilité qui fait que lille a du mal
à assumer son offre sans valeur et je me
suis pour commencer ce roman en fait je
suis parti d'une statistique qui
montrait que dans l'échelle du bonheur
puisqu'il ya un organisme qui étudie le
et celle du bonheur
en classant les pays du monde entier eh
bien nous étions en france très très mal
placée et quand on arrivait très très
bon après des pays qui vivaient dans des
situations de guerres de conflits
pouvant table dans des dictatures
alors pourquoi sommes nous si malheureux
et c'est ce que se demande si mon
personnage c'est vrai que les afghans
dans ces classements sont besoins sont
plus heureux que nous sommes par exemple
les mexicains qui connaît ses atouts et
elles sont très difficiles et tous les
pays d'amérique qui sont mieux classés
que nous par exemple alors que selon nos
critères il vit des situations plus
compliquées et d'ailleurs on est le pays
qui prend je crois le plus
d'antidépresseurs aussi enfin deux
tentatives de suicide aussi très un
recours aux psychiatres psychologues
très élevée aussi
voilà donc le personnage se retrouve
avec cette cette situation et ce conflit
intérieur qu'ils essaient de résoudre
oui alors il y aussi de deux personnages
réels qui apparaissent dans votre roman
le premier c'est michel houellebecq dans
votre héros qui a les mêmes initiales et
parce que ça d'auteur et il ya aussi
emmanuel macron alors là les traqueront
le mettre carrément en transe c'est
aussi riche et que ça vous fait
exactement bien sûr jeu
je parle de vent à travers ce roman bien
sûr vous l'avez compris c'est que le
personnage mener à une passion absolue
pour emmanuel macron et les promesses
d'un monde meilleur
les cartes qu'il va mal il a recours à
des vidéos de campagne électorale de
discours électoraux où on nous promet du
monde alors on est prôné une félicité ou
en contre un vote on va avoir un
personnage providentiel donc michel
hache a besoin de croire au personnage
providentiel
alors il a eu un gros évidemment pour
lui c'est le sommet de de la province
il faut dire que j'ai écrit ce roman
tout début après la campagne électorale
il faut dire que les choses se sont
riches à dégrader depuis et qu'il a du
mal à l'imaginer manuel da cruz incarne
et je voudrais c'est vrai et alors votre
michel haas évidemment vous vous dites
d'ailleurs il a toujours été un enfant
triste un adolescent cafardeux avant de
heurter un adulte neurasthénique et
c'est un peu raté en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on appelle un un anti héros est ce
que justement par la figure 91 euros que
vous aimez quand même souvent dans vos
romans
on voit mieux on arrive mieux à cerner
ce qu'est notre société justement par
des gens qui la détourne un peu des
injonctions qu'on voudrait nous nous
donner oui on est une société qui nous
condamne à être des anti héros dans la
mesure où comme je visais le confort
matériel que nous connaissons préserve
de la majorité des difficultés nous
sommes effectivement il faut bien avoir
conscience très assisté au quotidien
dans tout ce que nous faisons
la guider et des toute difficulté peut
trouver une solution par l'ordre social
par l'état auxquels on a recours à
carman ans on le voit bien d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui est donc ce n'est pas
une situation propice aux héros il est
évident que les situations de crise une
situation de difficulté donne beaucoup
plus de chances à des héros de ce
d'exister c'était s'il estime ankara
michel angel h n'a pas de combats à
mener il n'a pas de d'héroïsme à
exprimer et cette absence de perspective
ce bonheur qu'on lui finalement qui lui
était la naissance trop me l'empêchent
d'exister au fond est ce que justement
parce qu'on parlait de ses livres de
développement personnel
il y a un peu cette injonction à être
heureux ce qu'on appelait la tyrannie du
bonheur ça vous effraie un peu non ça
nous faisait face pour ce top 10 grâce à
nous mais il reste sur sa vie puis sur
des épaules que les générations
précédentes n'avaient pas nous sommes
des générations ou et les par exemple on
a tous la possibilité de faire des
études donc de façon facile accessible
gratuite
ceux qui sont donc un échec vont porter
cette responsabilité
ce seront eux qui seront la cause de
leurs propres échecs quand on dit
maintenant enfant tu peux faire ce que
tu veux tu es libre de choisir ce que tu
veux de faire les études que tu veux la
carrière que plus rien été imposées à ce
niveau là si je suis à l'échec
c'est ma faute et donc cette idée que la
être individuel pose énormément de
problèmes à michel houellebecq
à partir du moment où on peut rejeter la
faute sur quelqu'un d'autre c'est
beaucoup plus facile de vivre avec ça de
dire ah si j'avais pu j'aurais réussi
alors que là on peut tout est ouvert
donc si on échoue c'est notre faute et
on l'a dit dans tous vos romans il ya
cet humour et ce goût de l'absurde
d'ailleurs au début de votre livre vous
faites référence à camus l'étranger
c'est le livre de chevet de michel et
berri sera de sauver
élève de cheveux il faut dire ce que ça
veut dire sert akalé le meuble bon on le
sait camus a beaucoup travaillé sur le
sur la question du bonheur il
ad'ailleurs revisiter le mythe de
sisyphe sisyphe c'est celui qui pousse
son rocher au sommet d'une montagne du
bon indéfiniment puisque ce rocher
retombe à chaque fois et en analysant le
mythe de sisyphe et bien la solution
camus consiste à avoir l'absurde c'est à
dire intégrer au fond cette idée selon
laquelle il ya une absence totale de
d'espoir et une à une insatisfaction
consciente
alors est ce que comme camus et vous
voyez vous aussi dans ce duo qui vous
accompagnent le rire et l'absurde est ce
que vous voyez un art de vivre pied de
nez au désespoir
oui c'est ça c'est camus effectivement
fait le constat de l'absurde comment
réagir par rapport à ça il voit deux
solutions soit le souci qui soit la
révolte
je pense que l'humour doit être la
troisième voie activement pour une
société où il est difficile de se
révolter
quoique on voit justement que dans notre
société où on est dans une jeudi un
confort l'instabilité très importante
les révoltes augmente de plus en plus
donc il doit y avoir là quelque chose
qui est lié à ce constat de l'absurde de
nos vies et sinon l'humour est une
révolte aussi à sa façon
mais karl peut être violente aussi mais
elle est souvent plus en douceur et
j'imagine que dans mes romans c'est plus
en douceur que dans cette eau douce rsr
et ses pots etc voilà c'est à la fois
aux horribles coup réfléchit aussi notre
société à d'autres conditions
ça s'appelle donc le bonheur est au fond
du couloir à gauche j'espère que vos
élèves lisent et j'essaie de dire mais
c'est chez buchet chastel merci
infiniment merci beaucoup
[Musique]
on